gabbard just came out today and saying
what she says I'm leaving the Democratic
party did you guys see that how amazing
a one minute video she says I'm leaving
the Democratic party and she doesn't say
where she's gone she just said she's
leaving the Democratic party right and
it's you can go on our Twitter I don't
know if you have it or not if you want
to just play it uh uh you you send me
the Tweet if you just want to play that
up just go to her Twitter account and
you should that's it yeah
and what do you think she's gonna go Pat
if she's going to go to the right or
think she's gonna stay right in the
middle no I don't know no this when was
this uh says yeah but let me ask you is
anyone shocked by this like I I feel
like she's been at war with the
Democratic party for I mean it's like
not Andrew yeah
I'm not shocked by this whatsoever but
here's this is not about being shocked
or not I'm not I'm not expecting anybody
to be shocked but you had a superstar on
your side you can't lose Superstars like
this on your side you had Joe Rogan on
your side you had Elon Musk on your side
you had all these people on your side
that you're losing you cannot
continuously lose Superstars the example
was made yesterday about CNN versus Fox
and I said to uh the the lady that was
here with us and has any newer I said
listen
most Persians in L.A I don't know why
they're all on CNN Camp no it's not true
it's 50 I said it's not 50 50. it's more
like 60 40 if not higher she says no
it's 50 50. I said okay fine I said look
at CNN the model doesn't work they lied
for five six seven years and people left
them oh you're saying Fox doesn't like
you don't think fox has a uh what was
the word she was using like uh
of course they're bias of course they're
buys they're selling but they're giving
you information the left is just
repeating the same thing over and over
again in you CNN specifically nmsnbc
look what happened to their viewership
and I give the example I said you ever
had somebody talk [ __ ] about a
restaurant that's busy and you go to it
you're like why is she talk so many bad
things about a restaurant but every time
I go there I gotta wait 30 minutes why
is this restaurant so bad I said CNN is
a restaurant that's empty while people
say it's great Fox is a restaurant
that's full while people say it sucks
yeah eventually people get to go and eat
food at a place yeah that's full to say
what the hell is going on here people
are starting to ask maybe I have
something wrong and I gotta hear a
different perspective that's all it is
that's why a lot of these podcasts are
doing good yeah
Joe Rogan today to the world is
considered a Republican and the last
thing he is
[Music]
no no to the left he's a republican yeah
I didn't say he's a republican yeah to
the left he's a republican just because
he's asking questions did you guys see
the clip with the Rolling Stones founder
being on his podcast yesterday or like
sometime this week uh yes the one that
he annihilated is that the one yeah did
you see that I saw some of it who was he
he's like the government should regulate
they're better at regulating the
internet yeah and yeah it's a great clip
of him just like taking down this person
has this kind of sense of oh the
government like the government does good
and the government can be
transwinner yes that's exactly who it is
yeah but it was it was it was Advanced
that's exactly who it is that's exactly
who it is I was on don't play but that's
exactly who it is and Joe just
challenged them over and over and over
and over and and the guy is just
oblivious he's like no you know that's
exactly what it is the government's
better at it the government's better at
it the government's better at it he says
it's not the politician it's the
government and Joe says that's the
government no it's the politician Joe
that's the government no it's
politicians you that's the government
the government kept going back and forth
so people through dialogue and exchange
and conversations are starting to really
ask questions yeah which is kind of cool
when you say like the Democrat Party
needs the Tulsi gabbards or the Joe
Rogan's you know you're thinking about
policy because Joe Rogan is someone and
Chelsea gabbard as well they come out
they support things like single-payer
they support policies that Democrats
like but they're not representative of
the left anymore I mean AOC is
representative of the left this hard
woke stuff this stuff that talks about
kids and surgeries with to you know
gender surgeries and you know gutting
um you know everything that really made
the country great in terms of freedom
and values that that is what the left
represents so I don't think there's a
home for them anymore there the question
for me becomes where do those people go
where do the Joe Rogan's who still
espouse a lot of policies similar to
what the left used to be where do they
find themselves like where does Tulsi
gabrado does she hop on debate stage now
and present a problem for the left and
right because she's a common sense
person she doesn't align herself with
one side or the other I think that's
good let her hop on that debate stage
and force the Ron desantises of the
world and it's not going to be Joe Biden
so Kamala Harris whoever forced them to
be better at what they do challenge them
the the problem is is that I don't know
how somebody like a Tulsi gets elected
because she's conservative in some sense
but then you look at issues like
abortion and you look at single-payer
and and people like people want someone
who fits in a box you know people still
want that they're going to be confused
by a Tulsi gabbard they're going to be
confused by a Joe Rogan but I think the
market needs someone like a tall
cupboard or even an Andrew Yang someone
in the middle for sure to challenge both
sides yeah I mean it's if you look at
both parties I mean who's going to be
supportive of the whether it's the DNC
or the RNC you got to have someone
behind you we've learned that from
multiple people that have been on here
unless you have a party behind you a
platform behind you it's going to be
hard to basically
Galvanize your party right I mean the
Trump self-funded so he kind of there
was not a lot of people in the RNC were
basically behind Trump but you know
because he had his own money he was
doing his own thing but I think there's
such a yearning and such a fervor out
there for someone in the Middle Ground
common sense that whether it's a Tulsi
or a Yang or whoever's in the middle
that the country does want something
like that I just don't know if the
question is where do they go yeah her
question is what did it go
I mean looking at her like that's a
great clip that she said this morning
Freedom you know all of fantastic I'm
not going to vote for her because she
supports single-payer she's still a big
government girl she's just a big
government girl that's not grounded in
woke crazy so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]